[Музика]
привіт, хлопці, настав час уроку англійської,
мене звати Наталія Лесько, давайте
почнемо, тому, як ви бачите, ми все ще на
кухні, я ношу форму, і ви
можете побачити інгредієнти, так що ви
правильно, ми будемо мати
урок кулінарії минулого разу, коли я попросив вас проголосувати
за страву, яку ми будемо готувати,
номер один був тірамісу, номер два був
грецький салат, а номер три був донер-
кебаб, тому дуже дякую
кожному студенту, який  проголосував за страву,
і я дуже радий повідомити, що ми
збираємося готувати тірамісу, тому, будь ласка,
дотримуйтесь уроку, дотримуйтесь інструкцій,
ви можете приготувати страву з нами або пізніше
ви можете приготувати свою власну страву, а потім
кінець уроку I'  Я розповім вам
інструкції щодо змагань, тож
давайте почнемо та переглянемо
інгредієнти, які нам потрібні для тірамісу, щоб
перш за все ви пам’ятали, що нам
потрібні яйця, добре, нам також потрібен сир
, подивіться, це сир маскарпоне,
який я приготував  це для вас
пам'ятайте з попереднього уроку, що
наш дуже відомий гість у 30 - Браво сказав
нам, якщо у вас немає сиру маскарпоне,
це добре, ви можете замінити його
будь-яким вершковим сиром або поєднанням
сиру та жирних вершків, давайте
йти далі, у мене також є це
я знаю, що багато хто з вас
скажуть какао, але це український
еквівалент, скажімо англійською, какао
і ще раз какао какао-порошок
дякую дуже, тому какао-порошок ми
посипаємо його зверху, що ще ви бачите,
хм
Я бачу щось біле, що це за
цукор, добре зроблено
Браво, тому нам знадобиться цукор, насправді
ми додаємо цукор в наші десерти, рухаємося далі.
попросіть вас використати слово ladyfingers, тож
давайте скажемо ще раз ladyfingers і знову
ladyfingers. Молодці, а що це,
це кава, нам також потрібна кава для
тірамісу,
тому ми збираємося поглибити ladyfingers
у каву та п  відправляйте їх у пустелю. У
мене також є деяке обладнання, тож дозвольте мені
назвати, що у мене тут є, щоб у мене була
маленька миска, у мене була велика миска і величезна
миска, як ця всіх трьох розмірів, у мене також
є міксер, тому ми збираємося змішувати
все і також збийте, так що
це віночок, нам також потрібен він, і в мене є
ніж, і я маю до вас питання
це геть не
грайся з ножем небезпечно добре, у мене
також є ложка, і це велика
ложка, ми називаємо її столовою ложкою, скажімо
знову столова ложка, браво,
а що це, це маленька ложка,
ми називаємо її чайною ложкою, так знову столова ложка
чайна ложка столова ложка чайна ложка
це чайна ложка ні, це не так добре, добре
зроблено, і я також маю це, тому подивіться, якщо
повторіть за мною, подивіться, чи все гаразд, ми
збираємося використовувати це, щоб посипати зверху какао-
порошком,
і тому я думаю, що ми майже  готовий
розпочати, але перш ніж це зробити,
дуже важливо, що вам потрібно t  o зробіть
саме, щоб помити руки,
я вже вимив руки, будь ласка, якщо
ви ще не вимили руки до цього,
і ми йдемо, тому почнемо з яєць,
а потім у мене є запитання до вас, що
ми зазвичай робимо  шийку, то я
візьму бантик велику миску і малу,
мені також знадобиться ніж, тому я збираюся
розбити яйце, тому я розбиваю його, і я
збираюся відокремлювати білки від жовтків, тому
відокремлюємо яйце давайте  йдіть обережно,
щоб сюди їли тільки білки, а жовток
нам він не потрібен, він йде в окрему
миску, добре, для тірамісу,
нам знадобиться чотири яйця, давайте знову з
наступним, що ми робимо розбиваємо і
відокремлюємо молодець,
готовий це  номер чотири Немає номеру
три,
так що знову перерві та розлучись, добре
зроблено, а останній номер чотири
окремо зараз, перш за все, перерви, давайте підемо
ідеально, так що моя дружина вже і мої
жовтки вже подивіться, ви бачите
жовтки, то що ми зазвичай робимо  з
білками і жовтками з
Райтами ми можемо використовувати віночок і
збираємося  для цього збийте їх я
скористаюся міксером, це буде швидше, але
з жовтками ми робимо по-іншому, тому
ми
подрібнюємо жовтки, тож давайте я збиваю жовтки, а
для цього давайте порахуємо до 10 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8  9 10 добре зроблено, тому
ми будемо жовтками і залишимо їх
на секунду, продовжимо з білками,
щоб почати змішувати, я скористаюся міксером
добре, це буде важко, давайте
почнемо
в якийсь момент  ви продовжуєте збивати, але
ми додамо трохи цукру, тож давайте
підемо зі мною
[Музика],
щоб ви могли перевірити дроти, як це,
якщо суміш трохи рухається, тому, ймовірно, вона ще
не готова, давайте ще трохи перемішати,
тому я думаю, що ми  Ви готові, вам це не
потрібно, тому дозвольте мені показати це, щоб
суміш не рухалася, ви можете
спробувати так, давайте піднімемося, зараз це не
піде, так, все готово, тому будьте обережні з
цим, краще цього не робити  подібне,
тому що суміш може потрапити на
ваш капелюх, тому просто спробуйте трохи посунути м’яч,
він не рухається, тому він готовий, добре
зроблено, тому я  буду використовувати наступну миску для
сиру і для вершків, добре, тому я
приклею свої жовтки, а тепер я додам трохи
вершків, і вони мають питання, що
ми робимо з вершками, тому ми кладемо його
в миску і робимо ставку  разом з
жовтками ви зберігаєте, тому ми закладаємо, що сир
збиває сир,
вам потрібно дуже сильно збити, тому
нарешті суміш готова, подивіться добре, тепер
нам потрібно з'єднати ці дві суміші, тому
ми обережно додамо віночки
білки в вершкову суміш, давайте,
так робимо це потроху так і почніть
знову збивати суміш, коли ви додасте
збиті білки, вона буде дуже
пишною до книги Nasta
і Mossad, тому я додам усі білки
та ризик у цьому  якщо хочете
, можете додати трохи ванільного цукру,
подивіться,
ммм, це приємно пахне,
тому сирна суміш готова, нам більше не
потрібні віночки,
добре зроблені, тепер давайте приберемо стіл
для десерту, тож почнемо готувати, щоб у
нас був крем  Готовий у
нас є какао-паук Ladyfingers  дер і
трохи кави, тож я збираюся використовувати цей
маленький бантик для десерту, ви також можете
використовувати лише тарілку, тож давайте почнемо
зі столової ложки і
на дно тарілки кладемо трохи вершків, наприклад, 1
столову ложку, трохи потім  ми йдемо
з ladyfingers, оскільки ви бачите, що моя миска
не така велика, тому, ймовірно, я
розламаю їх навпіл так, так що ви
пам'ятаєте, що актор сказав вам, так робіть це
дуже швидко, не дозволяйте їм сидіти в
каві так  давайте киньмо ось так, а
ти покладеш пальчики поверх
крему, нам потрібно повторити дії,
давайте більше крему ladyfinger
Я думаю, тут я можу додати ще один ''s go
and cream again ladyfrings і ще один,
так що крем зверху ще трохи  чи буде кричати,
це ніколи не вистачає, давайте зробимо це
красивим, а тепер ми скористаємося ситом і
покладемо трохи какао-порошку зверху, тому будьте
обережні з какао-порошком,
якщо ви дуєте занадто швидко
, какао-порошок буде скрізь, тож давайте
використовувати чайну ложку для  це так сито і
чайна ложка готові так давайте
Я думаю, що цього достатньо, тож, схоже,
мій десерт готовий, я додам
сюди жіночий палець, щоб прикрасити його,
так що подивіться, це виглядає дивовижно,
зараз давайте переглянемо інструкції, перш за
все, ви розбиваєте яйця та розділяєте
вина та жарти  давайте почнемо з
жовтків, щоб ви збити жовтки і додайте трохи
цукру, а потім додайте сир маскарпоне
, змішайте їх разом і залиште
суміш, потім перейдіть до білків,
щоб збити яєчні білки з
цукром, коли суміш стане дуже стійкою,
потім  Ви з’єднуєте ці дві суміші,
і суміш має бути дуже кремовою, як
ця, пам’ятайте, тому наступні
вказівки – зібрати десерт,
щоб взяти столову ложку вершків, покласти
її на дно тарілки або будь-якої
миски, а потім додати пальчики, але перед
ви додаєте пальчики, занурюйте їх у каву
дуже швидко, не дозволяйте їм сидіти в
каві, тому ви повторюєте дії
крем ladyfinger cream lady finger
cream lady finger і закінчуєте
з кремом make it very  гладьте, а
потім посипте какао-порошком зверху, щоб
тірамісу був готовий, і дозвольте мені перевірити вас, щоб ви могли швидко перевірити,
тому давайте переглянемо питання номер один,
які інгредієнти для тірамісу п'ять
секунд, щоб переглянути
три два одна зупинка, будь ласка
, назвіть їх X  цукор
сир сир маскарпоне або будь-який інший
вершковий сир ladyfingers какао-порошок
і кава
не забувайте про каву кава важлива
добре, ми закінчили з інгредієнтами
питання номер два, так що ви можете зробити
з яйцями під час приготування десерту
знову п'ять секунд для вас добре  зроблено
так назвіть слова звукові сигнали окремий збій
що ще
злама добре зроблено та запитання номер
третє, так що ми робимо з какао-
порошком, ви посипте його чи поставте
, що є правильною відповіддю
так, це посипати, дуже дякую
на початку  нашого уроку я розповідав
вам про конкурс, це
насправді ваше домашнє завдання для проекту
виберіть свою улюблену страву, а
не подивитеся на Ностромо і складіть
список режисерів  розділи та інгредієнти, але якщо ви
робите це конкретну та готову енергію, яка,
окрім jock trabajo до води для очищення,
тоді переконайтеся, що у вас є
готові всі інгредієнти, і ви можете зняти це
та завантажити у свій
обліковий запис у соціальних мережах, використовуючи хештеги
shamash doma та  На уроці англійської мови ви можете
бачити хештеги на своєму екрані, тому,
хлопці, коли ви збираєтеся знімати свій
рецепт, переконайтеся, що ви дотримуєтеся
інструкцій, які я хочу, щоб ви зробили, тому я
насправді не зацікавлений, і величезні довгі
відео роблять його коротким  як можна
ось так, то наслідуйте моєму прикладу, подивіться
на інгредієнти, які мені потрібно використовувати для
моєї улюбленої страви, ви можете побачити яйця какао-
порошок ladyfingers кава вершковий сир,
щоб ви побачили, що я збираюся готувати
тірамісу, тепер дотримуйтесь інструкцій, а
ви  скажіть, як розбити яйця,
збийте білок і жартома сир додайте
цукор, потім зберіть десерт, щоб
використовувати крем ladyfingers крем ladyfingers
і посипати какао-порошок
поверх десерту,
тому насолоджуйтеся їжею  tiramisu,
це відео, яке я хочу, щоб ви
зняли, не робіть його довгим, зробіть його якомога коротшим.
Я хочу почути вашу англійську,
тому розмовляйте англійською під час створення відео,
або ви можете скористатися Планом Б для
домашнього завдання, якщо не  Я хочу зняти це на відео,
просто запишіть свій улюблений рецепт і
надішліть його мені безпосередньо, я збираюся
перевірити його, щоб ви могли бачити мою адресу електронної пошти
зараз на екрані. Я чекаю на ваші
рецепти, хлопці, тому всі ви ті, хто
якщо ви завантажите відео, отримаєте
подарунок для мене, а ті, хто знову пришле
мені ваші рецепти, ви отримаєте
наклейку, дуже дякую за
урок до наступного разу, до побачення
[Музика]